欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
哇 昨天才在讲台股叫做世界强
昨天台股沉浸在
灰达投资联发科可转载的快乐中
觉得我们是一个AI半导体的强国
这件事情没有改变
但是市场的气氛
难免还是看一下美股的脸色
美股現在確實還是有點陰霾
陰霾就在9月現在升息的機率高達70%
每一站打不停又有油輪被炸了
油價又狂飆直逼百元大關
通膨的疑慮起來了
高科技股就下去了
這些事實不能忽視
但今天的台股呢
相較之下是把昨天的漲點
幾乎全數吐回
而外資昨天買的今天更是大賣了900多億
空单也通通空回来
这两天好像原地踏步
好 但是接下来9月的发展
我刚刚有讲了
台湾的体质没有改变
台湾AI的发展没有改变
所以在这样原地踏步
甚至有点受到压力的情况下
该如何选股
我们什么时候才能再创新高
来宾心中是有答案的
来欢迎他们
第一位是K线之神
朱家宏 朱老师
好 朱老师说
台股已经回到这个多头轨道上
现在是小小的挫折
但是上效背景的朱老師要來講
沒有想到每一站
從3月打到現在
絲毫不和緩
到底什麼樣的情況下
有機會稍微落幕
不要再這樣影響到美股跟台股
等一下聽聽看
朱老師的沙盤推演
在這樣的情況下
目標價沒有改變
可是可能有點延遲
不妨回頭來看
很多朋友這段時間
信心又有點被磨掉了
可能有的股票漲上來
剛解套你覺得要賣
卖了之后又飞走了
所以不要再重蹈覆车的话
帮您检验
例如光学
光学真的超级强
会不会有这样的感受
好不容易抱了一小段时间就飞走了
机器人有点没耐性了吗
但形态其实好转
等一下朱老师帮您检验哦
好第二位是我们的产业趋势专家
王建文 王博
看到王博就会想说
一定要送暖的啦
我们9月不是有半导体展吗
但是美股也有9月魔咒
两个PK谁会胜出呢尤其是在半導體當中大家看到封測股好委屈先進封裝全世界在搶為什麼我們的封測股物美價廉
但是大戶偷偷在收喔
然後另外呢是CPU
王伯有發現聯亞創新高啦
全新創新高啦
還有很多驚天表態光盛驚天
漲停板告訴你
第一位接千張大戶在增持的CPU
還有誰喔
好第三位是我們的報價天王幸福哥
好天王駕到天王要告訴大家
昨天美股還是有好消息的
戴爾的財報連續兩季
市場非常的驚艷
幫伺服器代工按一個讚
好但是按下去之後到底要選誰
另外也要來看天王幫大家回顧記憶體
現在的情況
越納爾科打到月線是不是好機會呢
還有如果大家覺得電子股的風浪大
上個船吧
什麼東西在漲
散裝的運價默默漲漲
漲了一年 漲了半年了
所以散裝如何挑
回後買上漲
等一下告訴您
首先有請朱老師
你好
朱老師這個美衣
真的是沒有想到
越打越兇
那這邊的話
光學這段時間
真的超級強
但也很多朋友說
都抱不住 抱不到現在
機器人則是
一直在第一位接晃
你要告訴大家 快點火了
不要隨便賣
對 我們看一下
這個美衣戰爭
已經拖了半年了
也打了很久
基本上我個人認為
要停火是很困難
很難說
因為兩邊都不願意讓
所以很困難
但是全面大戰也不太容易
那因為美國只有用空襲
他也沒有辦法破伊朗來投降
你就是來炸炸
我就躲到防空洞裡面
就讓你炸就好了對不對
好 那沒有辦法登陸的話
就沒有辦法佔領伊朗
所以他要推翻政權也不太容易
那雙方都經不起長期消耗
最後還是要回到談判
所以就一直來來回
對 那只是說不知道在
不知道在什麼狀況下
那現在目前
因為最近又緊張起來了
他又在打
那最近油價會再上漲
降期的機率變很小了
那全球的股市都會受到壓力
所以基本上台股
不可能不受影響
雖然我們的後面經濟都很好
長遠看絕對沒有什麼問題
但是在短期受到這些消息還是會受到一些影響我們本身來講過了這個高點就要去闖利時高點
昨天其實氣勢很強
對 但是就還差一點
我上次有講這個地方的量是很大
這個地方最大量到1.8 1.9兆
所以這個地方的量還不夠
現在只到1.3 1.4
所以過高以後如果要過
就是要不但要漲
還要量要放出來
那昨天的量其實是縮的
是 昨天有上漲
但量是縮的
所以再加上今天消息面不好
又更縮 它又下來
好 我們先看
我們先看技術面的趨勢
有沒有危險
如果有危險
大家當然就要開始避險
那昨天上漲
它把這個46402已經過
所以在多頭來講
這已經過千高了
那今天又跌破五均
所以這個叫回檔
多頭就是過了這個高點
那這個就叫回檔
那回檔是準備做多的
我們都是回後買上漲
那回檔的話最重要是
支撐不要跌破
支撐不破
好 那我們就注意一下
最好就是趨勢不要破壞掉
月線季線只要不要跌破
這個還是一個很好的多頭架構
那只要能夠維持在上面
去消化一下這些離空
那我們的第四季
我一直講第四季
基本上還是向上看
還是向上看
好 那我們看一下
這兩檔很重要
台積聯發科因為前兩天
突然有一個外資的預測價
調到6000吧
而且昨天漲停板說是
就因為消息第二天就漲停
因為這個揮達
要買他的可轉
在昨天大激勵
這支股票4400是近期的高點
所以它前面一定是怎麼樣
頭頭高 它近期高點
所以這支股票它上面是頭頭高
可是你不要忘了
下面是底底低
是這樣看嗎
為什麼不能看這樣底底高
因為它這邊改了
這邊是多頭 但又破低了
所以TOTAL又改變了
所以它進到喇叭的盤子
所以不管是這根紅黑
還是漲停板
其實它都在喇叭的盤整區裡面這個地方不是買點我們都知道買點不可能买在第三天嘛要买在第一天可是有一个地方就是这是喇叭嘛
对
所以这个地方是压
那今天也是因为这个压
所以就下来
再加上大盘不好
是
其实他今天比大盘价
他开很高
没错 他开很高
大盘一开就下来了
他延续昨天的气势
对
所以他今天很
他今天是按照他该走的
但因为他碰到压
它碰到自己的压4400
那下面这个是喇叭的支撑
换句话讲
它今天没有过这个高点
所以它其实还在喇叭里面盘整
目前还在喇叭盘整
那未来的话
如果它把4400突破
那因为喇叭是形态
那这个地方加一倍
所以是在这个价钱
当然这个跟这个还差很远
用形态来计算的
对 形态算的
但是也不要忘了
如果到了5.1.45
他就會到這邊來
因為他也過了這個歷史新高了
他把這個壓力也過了
5.1.45就過了歷史高點了
那當然他再去攻這邊
也是機率蠻大的
好 好不好
只不過後面
我們要不斷地去追蹤他
看看他的變化
好
台積電視這一陣子
最沒表現
但也沒有變壞
也沒壞事
也沒好事
那我們上次有講過
它在這裡怎麼樣
還在這邊潛伏的
潛伏
它潛伏在這個地方
它是收斂的
這邊是喇叭
它必要要用它的時候
它就來了
它就出來了
比如說要護盤
要供歷史高點
要表態
對 它就會出現
所以這一陣子
看它的表現
它就是累積
站立在這邊
一直累積在這個地方
為什麼
因為這邊都有量
這裡有偷偷的大量
这根大KK就在这啊
就在这
所以它一直在这个地方
在这边累积
所以哪一天大盘要转强
还是要看台积电的表现
所以当天台积电如果能过
当然也是一样
挑战力是高点
那我们的大盘应该也就化解
其实现在也没有危机
我刚讲不是跌一天就变成危机
要整个趋势有改变
重要的关键被跌破
這個我們只是
早上美股大跌的關係
好 沒事的
昨天還創了反彈高
對
只是離歷史新高
剩一千多點 大家心癢難難
沒錯
朱老師要告誡大家
不要一解套就把它賣掉
就會賣飛
也不要追在不對的位置
因為一追就會套
我們現在要切記這樣的狀況
那我也講過
我們學做技術分析的
基本上你守紀律
你就不會被套牢
但是萬一你被套牢
每個人的心態就是想解套
對不對 趕快把本錢拉回來
所以一般來說
你如果被套牢了
如果到了解套的那一天
90%應該你都會賣掉
但是問題就是你能夠解套
都代表這次股票已經轉強了
如果它不轉強
你也不可能解套
所以你一賣掉
常常它就飛走了
你不要這樣
這樣看得起來心好痛
對
所以其實我們有幾個心法
給大家講
那第一個就是
你以後不要被解
不要被套嘛
先不要被套
因為你每次都經過一段掙扎
後來解套嘛
是
所以我們的最原始的原因
就是你被套了
對
所以先不要被套
那第二個
如果你真的被套了
那等解套嘛
是
如果你解了套
你為什麼會要賣
因為你也上次買就跌了嘛
對
那我現在又來了
我趕快賣
不然它又跌了
所以這是你的心理狀態
心魔
對
但實際上
你應該回到技術面
你上次因為不守技術面
所以被套了嘛
那現在你解套
請你回到技術分析來
也就是沒有跌破五軍
你就繼續爆
好 沒有跌破五軍
對 因為它轉強
我就沿著五軍爆嘛
而且你解套
基本上它都走了一個大波段
那你有可能明天就會跌破五軍
但也有可能它又因為轉強
它可能又繼續走
那你就守五軍就好
所以這是一個
解套當天要賣還是不賣的
最簡單的方法
如果你解套它飛掉了
我今天賣明天又漲了
你不要再追回來了
因為它本來就在高跌
只是它隨時都會回來
讓你萬一不回來
你不要連著五軍
你就多賺一點
可是你賣了又後悔
又要去追的時候
你是買在高檔
你跟上次套牢一樣
你又跑到高檔去買可是我馬上認錯啊朱老師心態好了我馬上認錯啊好 那就停損如果你有改回來說我不被套牢嘛那就是停損嘛
如果你去追
那明天跌你就趕快跑
好 要追就要承擔後面的結果
沒錯 否則你會歷史重演
我們這邊用現在最強的大力光
如果在這個地方被套
那就是沒有手機率沒賣
不要在這個地方賣掉對不對
大力光在歷史高點6000嘛
那你先 他後來打底到了5000
那可能你想說我還沒解套
那你還在報
你解套了
我解套了
你現在6000解套了
6000的朋友喊一聲吧
各位想
如果你解套是不是沿著五軍
今天還沒賣
按照這個嘛
按照這個邏輯
所以你沒有賣
那如果你一解套賣
哇 這個真的賣費了
現在快8000了
6000賣
6000解套漲到8000
別說6000了
這邊可能5000底會賣
對 都一樣
就看你在哪邊被套的
因為每個人套的地方不一樣
好 那我們把這個問題解決了
我們就剛好來看看
我們的光學股
大黑光是領頭羊
沒錯
它歷史最高還有玉金光
哇 這個都一直漲
全部都拉上來了
好 那我們今天還是一樣
好的股票
各位看大盤不管漲今天跌
它都不跌
它不跌
所以聯誼光
雖然我們在上次在底部有追蹤
對 其實很早以前就追蹤
上禮拜再追蹤一次
可是它目前還沒有轉弱
還是很強的股票
那現在它的技術面
表現的是K線橫盤
對
如果K線橫盤突破
也是一個我們多頭的買點
因為它已經到了所謂的目標價了
對
那目標價到了
趨勢沒有改還會再漲
還會再漲
金國光是在前兩天轉成多頭了
那既然有量有價又變多
那我們就回後來上漲就可以
所以這個比較單純一點
比較簡單
真的光學帶上
因為上禮拜朱老師幫我們看的
都續強 全部光學都續強
主要它是把架構做好
架構做好我們都可以去追蹤
好 那還有誰呢
那這裡的光學股現在很多
除了那兩檔
大裂光跟玉金光遙遙領先之外
可是其他很多的股票
有的還在轉成多頭
但有的還沒有走得很好大部分都變好了大部分都OK了那我們去看像今天亞光還漲停板嘉陵漲停板嘉陵也漲停板那我們來看一下好不好
這是標準的跳空多頭
因為沿著五軍你就不要追高了
因為它也靠近壓力
那我們等下次回來再買
你這邊有幫他畫圓湖底的目標價
這個已經走上來了
也是上禮拜講的
他也是跑到目標價
不過他今天是回後買上漲
今天嗎
今天紅K
是
昨天跌
今天大漲吧
昨天大盤漲他跌
今天大盤跌他漲
對
反股
所以各股歸各股
好 我們既然是多頭
我們就做
然後97.8
97.8過
那就會到目標價
就到目標價
大家練習看看
整個工學都打底好了
那機器人其實
今天有一些表現
像這個大盈維系統
今天看起來
它底部都做得不錯
全球傳動
我們也不妨去稍微的關注它一下
盟利今天是回後買上漲
因為它創高壓回
又變回後買上漲
我們都可以看看圖
大盈維
這是今天多頭確認
它今天收盤過這個高點
很清楚
一看就可以看得出來
這個高點還沒有到這條線
那今天收盤已经过了240
头头高
这个是底底高
那可是你不要追高
拉回来做
这也是从上面跌下来
也经过很长时间的整理
很长时间
那这个全球传动也一样
这个出现了底底高
那就等过高
一过高它就完成了
我们就可以继续去追
那大盘归大盘
各股跟各股
所以大家如果有看到底部整理的股票
不妨就去按技術面去追踪
索引一下就好了
好 雖然這個美一站這樣蠻煩人的
可是也可以看得出來
例如光學是整體轉向
沒錯
就可以優先先看這種對不對
好的類股還是會漲
這邊非常謝謝朱老師
朱老師要提醒
美一站恐怕會變成拖延的狀況
時不時就會擾亂盤面
但是台股的多頭態勢沒有改變
只是有點原地踏步有點拖延了再創高的時間沒有關係運營盤面上大家有看到吗光学股就是火种告诉您大盘虽然没有大表现的情况类股却在有很好的表现
回归到技术形态来做判断
如果您手上的股票刚解套
其实形态已经好转的
不要随便卖
那如果呢
第一时间也不要让自己被套牢
所以今天的课很好上
一定要学起来
机器人在底部打底也快完成了
就是在考驗我們的耐性
我們不妨就追蹤下去
好 廣告回來王博也要上場了
王博之前一路呵護的CPO
現在已經有領先部隊率先創新高的
但是低位階而千張大戶凝聚的也很多
半導體展裡面封測是現在最低估的
等一下幫您挑
好 我們的半導體展正式開展了
不過我們也有統計
通常在展期間
反而台股不容易上漲
但剛剛朱老師也有點名了
有些族群就是特別強
我們不妨來看一下火種在哪裡
這邊來請教王伯了
CPO真的幫你出了一口氣
超強 對不對
好 有一個部隊是已經創高的
聯亞然後全新 光環
但是今天光盛漲停了
所以第一位接的也會來
再來封測股
應該是這一波展覽
我覺得最委屈的
不是先進封裝
全世界在搶嗎
對 大家在搶產能嗎
其實台灣真的是得天獨厚
憑良心講
如果我們看到8月
8月的那個台股的漲幅是全球第一
是啊
然後大家在看說全球第一
結果呢
結果昨天衝上去之後
今天怎麼樣又跌下來
等於是原地太不
但是今天就算跌下來
那個體感溫度還是很高
我的看法
我的看法是最近蠻有趣的
就是說內支
投信也在大動作
特別是內支大戶也在大動作
這個是我說真的
我最近在整理資料過程當中
我覺得說 怎麼這麼積極
嚇一跳呢
不是九月魔咒嗎
怎麼這麼積極
所以我覺得啦
我覺得應該還有好戲啦
我們就來看啦
好 那我們先來看一下
哇 這大人物
麥威爾啦 谷歌啦 輝達啦
然後台灣 通通都來了
通通通通都來了啦
所以大家在想一個問題就是說
那為什麼台灣能夠那麼強
其實我們在整理喔
八月份喔
之前大家說
集中市場漲了百分之六點九八
就已經贏過納斯達克
贏過韓國股市 贏過日股
贏過飛升半導體
就是世界第一
對啊 然後電頭市場
竟然八月份漲了8%是15.4%
其實台灣就是得天獨厚
為什麼這麼強
除了國際半導體廠
我覺得這是台灣的主場
台灣的主場
那你看喔 揮答說好
誰受惠
好 台灣的廠商受惠
麥威爾說好 誰受惠
台灣的廠商受惠
對 說好
好 直接AI伺服器廠商受惠
還是台灣的那個廠商受惠
所以我為什麼認為說
其實不管是9月
9月搞不好
有機會去攻48218
甚至什麼
甚至第四季應該
應該都會有好戲
那当然包含像所谓的VR Rubin的交货
然后苹果新机的发表
现在都见在悬上
不得不发嘛
难道说我不出货了吗
那另外就是说
国际半导体展瑞银论坛
瑞银为什么来办论坛
报名牌
所以我们要特别留意
瑞银在讲什么
报名牌
外资论坛也会陆续开始
然后记底作帐
所以我会这样看
因为以目前看来
内资控盘包含像投信
包含像自营商
包含像内资大户
大家要注意
大戶回来了
因为前一阵子下修的时候
其实大戶也跑了蛮走
你有提到吗
有些少年股神大戶真的离场
但是这次真的有回来
真的是有回来
真的回来了
然后所以我认为
会持续的发挥我们的主场优势
但是我觉得
我们还是来看一下
这些大厂的看法
包含像麦威尔
我想麦威尔的技术长
特别提到
什么
台湾的细光子供应链
无可取代
那無可取代那就很清楚了
為什麼大家之前說好想贏韓國
現在想說什麼叫好想贏韓國
贏韓國太多了嘛
對不對 因為韓國大家都想說
他們除了財閥
對不對 除了HBM就是財閥嘛
對不對
然後就是所謂的霸凌
沒有 霸凌是我看Netflix看到的
那當然什麼 當然台灣怎麼樣
台灣就是產業的優勢
整個所謂AI的生態系
那當然其實邁威爾的技術長有提到
他認為說其實現階段就是一波一波
技術一波一波的往上推
然後量一波一波的放出來
所以他認為到2027年底到2028年初
這個時候怎麼這個時候就衝上
但是我仔細看一下
臺灣的相關的公司
其實營收獲利都有跳上來
所以也許啦
也許這個就是說
他開始有開始有點熱身
那當然大家會特別留意台積電
其實市場上
目前在那個追蹤的最重的一句話
就是說
台積電預估那個整體細光只要二零二七年市場的滲透率能夠超過超過50%對 請教王博怎麼會有這麼高的數字其實昨天有聽到
然後還有跟來賓也討論
他們說滲透率有個10% 15%就很好了
超過一半
大家原本估計
2026年的滲透率大概5%
他等於是直接跳上來
那直接跳上來
我想台積電他們
也不可能先喊先贏
或是不是說
其實這樣的一個標準規格
接下來就是持續的往前推進
如果說這樣的標準規格
持續往上推進的話
我覺得會不會超過50%
那當然由什麼
由市場來做檢驗
但是這個宣示
對 但是它代表什麼
代表那個光進同退的速度是加快
那如果光進同退速度加快
那當然什麼
當然我們之前在低檔的時候
跟大家講說好可憐好可憐
還被投信給放棄
但是現在不一樣
投信回來拼命買
所以這個就是大家要注意的地方
有時候投信也不是笨蛋
投信很多股票看到在低點的時候
他們就真的回來買
低點回來買那個力量都會特別大
所以我們要注意
那這是我們之前送了好多次的光盛
真的要送到不知道怎麼辦了
而且它是這一波反彈也算落後
可是今天一口氣站上所有均線
我覺得這個也是帶量
所以這個有機會了
我記得以前一開始
我們都把光盛當指標
後來你知道把它當指標
當到不敢把它當指標了
換成聯亞對不對
那個是因為這檔股票之間
我們怎麼講
大家都會有一個疑問
一個問號在那邊
是不是它的料源
缺料
營收開的不漂亮
然後你看這個股價
就這樣一路跌一路跌
現在慢慢勾上
目前看起來是有機會
那光寶科今天當然還有創一個高
那這個是我們之前講的
就是說之前大家認為
不會漲的股票都變標股
所以多找一些低位
有時候怎麼樣
有時候拿時間去等
對 那時間去等
那個產業的訊息發酵之後
就有機會了
光寶科對應到
大家可能想到是台達電
今天在跌幅排行榜也是前兩名
所以那個台達電後來我們就怎麼樣
我們就只能送暖
繼續送 希望能像光盛一樣
好 那這個是麥威爾技術長講的
細光子無可取代
所以現在的供應鏈是
一棒接一棒 好像接力賽
而且這樣的一個接力賽的
那個一棒接一棒的強度
說真的超過我的預期
因為我沒有想到說這麼強
那為什麼會超過我們的預期
我們來看這是投信投信低檔買然後越買越多這個是大戶已经要千张了因为我习惯我在整理的时候我提醒大家我们都先看400张大户
结果在整理的过程当中
哇 怎么千张千张千张千张千张
代表什么大家很勇于
很积极的投入
搞不好400张的都变千张了
对 而且他们很勇于
很积极的投入的过程当中
是赚钱的
所以我认为
我认为其实那支
在控盘主场优势的过程当中
他们的确控得很漂亮
那今天当然光盛
对
讯新
讯新KYA障厅
而且也有发酵豪雨
然后友达
我觉得友达
因为最近的顶元是冲上去
对
所以我觉得友达集团
顶元富财
友达你都要注意
是
那如果我们从这个
那个所谓的资料来看
我觉得还是可以看高做低
就是尽量找一些说
你认为说
进可攻退可守
好
那这张股票是文贸
邦邦文贸
其实我之前有帮大家追踪过
有
因为他也很不赏脸
也直接破
7月22号
我追踪他很久了
团进团灭差不多了
低点差不多到了
说实话那时候
已经大概320左右了
没想到还能再来一个
继续团灭
但是这一次怎么样
这一次就不一样
这是上来
但这次上来的过程当中
其实投信
投信蛮积极
其实302
没有真的差不多了
对
但是那种感觉就是说
好像好像機會來
那我要提醒大家一個重點
就是說因為它是全球最大生化甲
晶圓代工廠
但重點來了
現在大家不是看生化甲
看靈化音
它本身具備靈化音的製程
所以現在大家在看靈化音
包含像看聯亞
然後看全新
大家現在在看說
其實穩茂也是
然後它積極開發與驗證
靈化音的那個相關產品
所以我覺得
我覺得其實它有點落後很多
像全新
全新最近超強
所以我觉得稳貌
投信回来买不是买一天
所以我觉得这档股票
大家可以留意
那当然还是先给大家区间
因为有时候你要做短线的话
就先注意一下区间
然后除了所谓的那个稳貌之外
我们今天提一个新朋友
配亨
配亨我们真的很少讲
为什么会想到他
光迁
光迁概念
其实今天从中国大陆那边
有传一个讯息过来
光迁要涨价
因为现在什么
現在光簽廠的那個訂單幾乎
產能滿載 訂單都被篩爆了
然後目前看到那個所謂的配恩的訂單能進度到二零二七年然後他那個公司有出來說他就是要積極擴充產配衡本身是康寧供應鏈那現在有個問題
有個問題就是說
其實全球光纖缺口
達1.8億新公里
那你想想工期缺口那麼大
然後光纖價格含漲
重點是說
其實你要生產光纖
前面有一個光纖預製棒
那你那個光纖預製棒
你要從那個什麼
從所謂的蓋廠
然後裝機到生產
這個時間大概要一年半到兩年
所以你現在就是說
我要增產 緩不計及
所以我覺得以目前看來
這檔股票其實也是位階低
我們盡量幫大家找一些位階低的
然後獲利也不錯
所以我們可以注意一下說
這些個股的一個接下來的表現
就是看 對
都在那個長天 均線糾結區了
對對對 而且今天有小爆量
小爆量
所以我覺得大家可以留意
就是盡量找位階低的
然後接下來就是
其實這些都是好學生
對 先進封裝
不是大家都在瘋狂擴廠
找產能 漲價
那為什麼是漲這樣
其實還好
還好就是因為
有時候
有時候可能大家都去找好做的
但是如果說你要找
導線好做
有時候你就是要看
那個所謂的短線的高手
他們有時候會看資金往哪邊
好衝嘛 那個好進出
那我的看法是說
其實如果我們看
很簡單嘛
輝達要做晶片
然後超為要做晶片
然後谷歌要做晶片
接下來你要做那個
所謂的智研晶片的廠商
是越來越多
那你要想一個重點
那你要全部丟給台積電
你丟給台積電
那台積電好了
我先進製程的產能給你
但是問題先進製程產能給你之後
我要回到封裝
而且現在越來越多東西要封進去
所以就變成什麼
變成技術
還有所謂的那個相關的那個需求
就越來越高
那其實我們仔細看
投信是真的在买
所以一样是内置控盘
然后日月光的吴田玉
讲了一句话说
想象空间上看千倍万倍
这样的讲话就蛮令人
有点兴奋
但是我们也不能这样想
我们还是要看股价的表现
除了投信之外
当然一样
一样我们在整理
400张大户的过程当中
有些股票千张大户在买
所以我觉得
其实封装
很多都是好学生
有些好学生
我觉得你就是
蹲點你在那邊所謂守租待遇
我覺得該佈局要佈局
好 新權其實說實話
他也沒有什麼大漲
但是也算抗跌啦
就是看有沒有把火燒來這邊
因為有時候我們股票
在漲的過程上需要族群性
對 族群性
那其實你可以發覺
其實它就是一個區間
也沒有什麼
就是一直
就當然股災大家都倒楣啦 對
但它現在就回到這個地方來
但是如果我們看新權的話
你看台積電
然後客戶 谷歌 聯發科
聯發科現在跟那個
輝達好的不得了對不對
忽然變好了 對
那當然它本身要投資
280億美元去擴產
先進測試
不是先進測試的設備跟
智慧化的產線
然後它卡位矽光子
跟所謂的一紙整合風光
這就是展覽的重點
台積電也出來講
所以我覺得
我覺得這個大家
就可以留意好學生
好學生大家可以注意說
是不是有機會
我覺得其實說真的
距離前高也不遠
那如果說族群出來的時候
是有機會去挑戰前高
那另外一檔
其實就是矽格的子公司
台新科
其實我們今天講的
今天講的新權藥
那個台新科藥
都是好學生
也都離他的前面高點不算遠了
其實這一波跌的過程
然後上來的速度其實也
雖然說沒有很陡
但是上來也是都到均線之上
均線慢慢的勾上來
客戶就是超伟 博通 麥威爾
哇 麥威爾 連發科
都是他們
對對對
那其實他已經出來講
三麥米跟五奈米
其實他已經開始相關產品量產
積極搶進2奈米
所以就看嘛
看接下來是不是會有一些貢獻
那當然麥威爾
之前就有特別提到說
他跟麥威爾合作開發
矽光子相關產品
所以這些股票說真的
就是有時候就是等
有時候就等
好 但是確實均線已經糾結做好
那又是一個業績不錯的
又有大客戶加持
大戶如果又再買
對 其實有時候台新科
你說矽格 看那個新權
或甚至日月剛同
說真的你看他的營收獲利
沒什麼好挑剔的
就是看說什麼時候
族群性進來之後
就開始有機會表現
好 千萬不要等到
大家又一起發動的時候
因為其實今年也有
又才急急忙忙的追
今天非常謝謝王伯
謝謝趙花
好 最近台灣細光子的第一位
往上墊囉
麥威爾說
台灣是無可取代的
細光子的重鎮
那我們也從營收
或者是說他們的股價創新高
來證明了這件事情
剛好這個族群高低位階是有拉開來的現在低位階的也在表態了所以其實選擇還很多選擇更多的恐怕是在封測股了因為全球的先進封裝在台灣啊
那他們的位階相對低
其實股性好滿黏的
現在滿多檔都重新站回所有軍線之上
就等待發動
提供給您做選股參考
好 廣告回來
報價天王
幸福哥要來聊報價了
記憶體今天南亞科達到月線了
是不是一個好的時機點呢
散裝航運其實報價一直默默的在漲喔
要不要電子股風浪大
我們搭一下散裝船來幫大家來解讀了
好不可否認漲上來大家都很開心
但是美國升息的這個壓力
在美國的電子股確實是形成了一些陰霾喔
不過也有一些好表現
例如戴爾電腦已經連續兩季
一角出讓市場非常驚豔的
財報跟彩測
也讓我們的AI伺服器大廠們
有了一個助力
所以這邊來請教幸福哥了
戴耳電腦其實盤前是跌的
應該說在開盤的時候是跌的
但盤後漲了8個百分點
台灣的AI代工伺服器
看來也會接到好的訂單
散裝的運價其實默默
短中長期都在漲
所以要不要這個時候
分散一點資金去買船票
好 那當然最近這兩天
盤勢震盪非常大
昨天大漲
那今天幾乎快把昨天的上漲
給吃掉了
那9月來看的話
因為還是有一些變數
除了剛剛前面朱老師講的
美疫戰爭
還有9月16號的這個FOMC
那還有甚至最近
美國跟日本在談
就是說日本要不要升息
這個其實都是影響
這個全球資金的一個流動
所以我認為9月
特別是16號之前
就是FOMC開位之前
因為現在升息的機率
已經超過五成
市場可能還是會稍微等待一下
那外資當然最近
其實基本上空單是一路都很多
從七月 六月創新高到現在
七月大跌 八月
其實後來我覺得看這
已經沒什麼太大的意義
反正它都是避險單
昨天減了 今天一樣加回來
那比較有趣的是小台跟微台
怎麼樣
這個昨天終於翻空了
大家想說 哎呀 散步我們四
沒想到今天真的大跌
所以我們常常講說
這個壞掉的時鐘
一天也會準兩次
所以其實我是覺得大家除非你有在做期貨參考一下你看其實人家這次看對了今天賺了盤中我記得好像期貨跌的超過期貨有千點對七八百點
盤中一度快千點
所以我是認為說
如果你是做現股的話
重點還是在選股
因為今天盤不好
但是很多還是在衝
還在創新高
那當然昨天DALE的財報
盤後公布講得還不錯
那其實不管是估了第三家
全年其實都比市場的好
那年增率呢
都有五成以上
甚至接近100%
那目前GR的定量
也創歷史新高
连5G跑赢市场的预期
那他有特别提到
目前供应链最大的瓶颈
还是在记忆体
对 特别低润的部分
好 那今天其实
这个带了这个利多
让整个所谓
这个我们的这个组装厂商
其实今天大概算是稳盘
就是有涨有跌
但是涨跌幅
除了光宝科涨比较多之外
其实大部分呢
可能都是平盘附近上下震荡
特别是下游的组装
像鸿海 广达
其實最近都是還在持續的打底
那偽創是最近是比較強一點
還有像宏基
宏基其實應該說這個AIPC
不過我認為這個可能普及到
一般的消費者還沒那麼快
維穎最近也非常強
維穎最近很強
今天一菜山了
好那我們先來看一下宏海
宏海的話最近就是
他還是在一個季線跟半年線這邊
打一個相形底
那明年我們上次來有講過
上次跌到這裡
其實基本上送分底
因為10倍的本益底
但是我們如果認為
大盤9月16號之前要整理的話
你就不能去拉大型股
不能去拉台積電
不能去拉紅海
因為一拉這種大型股
指數很容易就創新高
所以這個會先整理
那季線就上上下下
月線就上上下下
這是紅海的情況
那廣達也是
廣達這兩天本來有挑戰季線
不過因為季線現在扣底的位置
還在這個前波高點附近
所以它現在扣下來的結果是
季線目前是下彎的
當然形成壓力
所以如果你是低檔坐上來
當然遇到這種
均线的短压你可以先做一趟短线卖出
这个也是可以的
就是这样做的话价差会比较多一点
所以像这种大型龙头股的话
在9月16之前
我认为要直接拉出一段的涨幅
其实比较不容易
除非说你有一个市场
非常看好的业绩或题材
类似像大力光年
以前没AI
现在突然有AI就直接拉出去
但是这个已经有AI
然后大家都已经很早就已经看到它的
其实目前大概
特别是权重比较高的
可能就以整理为主
那另外呢最近比較強的
下游組裝是維穎維穎創歷史新高那維穎是今天除息又除權那他在除息除全前一天還拉到創歷史新高7800那當然因為他股本小
他的這個籌碼也比較少
所以他這一次呢
除息之外又幾乎是一拆三
本來一張可以變成快三張
那當然他好處就是籌碼增加
然後呢股價也不會說
哇一張要700多萬800萬
這樣子的話增加他的流通性
我覺得公司這個做法是OK的
那今天呢
在初期的第一天
本来早上有稍微冲一下
不过很快要打下来
那我们预计
因为通常这种
这种就是储物比较多的
有比较大的跳空缺口
你可能要用所谓的还原来
不然的话你看这个
好像哇
怎么线都全部跌破了
好像是空头
其实不是
还是要用还原来看
那我觉得长线来看
因为微影的业绩
它的结单状况
一直是相当的不错
我觉得长线还是可以做一个追踪
这个除旋前
大家本来以为拆了
可以买到1000多块的微影
就涨那麼多
也只能再買到2000多塊的圍影了
對 那
剛剛我們看到DALE財報裡面有提到
GDR是很缺啦
那總體的需求來看的話
還持續的增加
工序的缺口還持續的擴大當中
那我們來看一下最新的報價
左邊這個是Netflix
這個是它的一個走勢
也是還蠻高的
對 然後呢這邊有DRAM
就DDR3、DR4跟DDR5平均
也是還在漲
那為什麼最近是GDRAM比較強
內的比較弱
因為主要是第三季的合約價
內的的漲幅是比較持平的
沒有像第二季那麼多
然後相對來講
低潤的漲幅還稍微比較大
所以最近有點差異化的情況
這個有點出現跟大家說一下
那再來的話呢
兩檔個股
一個是這個南亞科
南亞科我們上次來
其實剛好在一個相對低點
那我們是說
如果你基本面看好的話
其實破線反倒是
可能你可以进场准备低阶的时间点
那到今天
因为他是赚记忆体里面领先有创高的
世界第一强
对世界第一强
那其实目前的这个位置
他又稍微在高涨震荡
因为其他的还没上来
所以你说他一直冲
好像也比较不可能
因为族群性不够的情况之下
他可能会先在高涨震荡
等其他的慢慢慢慢爬起来
我觉得这几率比较高
所以通常要在高涨区的操作
其实简单来说就是低买高卖
你不要看漲停創高你去追
然後跌下來的時候
你會很緊張很想停損
或想把它賣掉
在高漲區的震盪來說的話呢
反而要掌握就是來回操作賺錢
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕